what's the worst experience you ever had
on a movie i did
one movie as a director where i was
working i i'd always had
great relationships with actors uh on
set
and i found myself working with a couple
of couple of actors
really talented people but they i at a
certain point i didn't know what was the
conflict why
there was resistance to talk about the
work
after the clock was punched a kind of
continuity of mission together
and i i sum it up as a generation
largely not entirely of actors
who are more interested in selling
movies than making them
and are on their cell phones you know
pro kind of staying in the loop of um
sending out uh you know social messaging
about the
the movie they shot a year ago that's
coming out and doing things that
that where there's there was lack of
what i consider kind of mission focus or
common focus
which is part of what i love about
making movies is that that kind of
family
that creates together nobody no director
directs alone you do it with all of
these inputs
and it and without a continuity if you
felt you couldn't make a call after work
that day and say hey
when we did the scene today don't you
think maybe tomorrow in the scene it'd
be great if we inserted this color
because we didn't get that in this one
or whatever it is that you're you're
trying to the picture you're trying to
paint
and i and and and that was surprisingly
and or
unsurprisingly uh a deeply
disappointing and and kind of
discouraging experience i didn't think
i'd ever want to make a movie again
and then i made a movie this last year
starring my daughter
and had the antithesis of that
experience just a great
thing so i am a a recovered uh filmmaker
yeah it would have been great if your
daughter like was on her cell phone the
whole time you were trying to make a
movie with her no dad i don't want to
discuss it
i don't want to discuss my you would
think anybody who's an actor who's
working with sean penn and you're
directing them
you would think it would be their joy to
sit there with you and get a
deep deep analysis of that character you
know what i mean i mean you
you've done enough movies where you've
proven yourself you at the very least
you think that person would say hey
maybe i could learn something from this
guy
jack nicholson said you were a great
director you can't get any better
accolades than that
he is a a director's dream
an angel on your shoulder uh you know
there's a there's a world in my
imagination where i just would have made
movies with jack for the
you know for both of our lives isn't it
intimidating though man when you got a
guy like that i mean
do you do you get nervous before you
direct the film or you are you kind of
in the zone now and it's
just not an issue the first movie i was
doing you know it went from me alone in
a room writing a script to
somebody surprisingly saying yeah let's
do this and the next thing you know
you're on a movie set with
a lot of professionals and a lot of big
trucks and a lot of money
pressure on your shoulders and you look
around you say where are the adults
who's going to call the plumber
um but but but
then you you find rhythm and then you
work something like jack
you know i suppose one could be
intimidated but he wouldn't let that
happen he
you know a pro and as talented as that
is comfortable in themselves enough to
to know that the way a movie works is
the sum of the parts that the director
is going to have to do and he's there to
help you
you